COMMITTEE- BUDGET- JUST OF
COUPLE A QUICK ANNOUNCES WE HAVE
TWO BILLS WHICH CAN BE HEARING
COMMITTEE TODAY- MARC MARTIN
FROM OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE WILL
BE PRESENTING S. B. ONE ONE
EIGHT- IN THE MISS ERIC WHICH IS
OUR WHICH IS OUR BUDGET TRAILER
BILL AND THEN MISS ERIC LEAD TO
PUBLIC FINANCE WILL BE
PRESENTING THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR WHICH IS S. B. ONE
EIGHTEEN. SB ONE NINETEEN L. A.
O. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL
AS ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS WILL
BE HERE AVAILABLE- ACCUSES ANY
QUESTIONS OTHERS NO VOTING
COMMITTEE TODAY- WERE OUT WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING A ONE MINUTE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PER PERSON IN THE
HERE AT THE END OF THE HEARING
IN THE HEARING ROOM AS WELL AS
ON THE PHONE- THE PHONE NUMBER
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE INTERESTED IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO OH TWO. AND THEN ALSO- IF
YOU'VE ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE CALL
THE BUDGET OFFICE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO OH NINE
NINE. SO BEFORE WE BEGAN TO BE
NOT NOT TO MIX OF JUST OPENING
COMMENTS- WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
S. B. ONE ONE EIGHT FOR QUITE A
FEW WEEKS WE OBVIOUSLY GOT. VERY
CONCERNING NEWS. FROM OUR
COURTS- THAT THEY WERE NOT
WILLING TO STAY A LOCAL JUDGES A
LOCAL ALAMEDA SUPERIOR COURT
JUDGE'S DECISION TO CAP A
STUDENT ENROLLMENT. AND JUST TO
REMIND THE PUBLIC THAT THE
STUDENT ENROLLMENT AT BERKELEY
AS WELL AS UNIVERSITIES AT UCCS
YOU COMMUNICATE ALL JUST. HAVE
ALL BEEN GROWING AT THE
DIRECTION OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE GOVERNOR. WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE FACED A TWO MILLION. DEGREE
SHORTFALL OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS BY THE TIME TWENTY THIRTY
COMES AROUND. AND THE ONLY WAY
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE TO
GROW ECONOMICALLY CONTINUE TO
GROW OUR FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD IS IF WE CONTINUE
TO. ALLOW PEOPLE ACCESS TO OUR
WONDERFUL HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM AS WELL AS WE CAN KEEP IT
AFFORDABLE SO BERKELEY AS WELL
AS ALL THE OTHER STATIONS HAS
BEEN GROWING. AT OUR REQUEST AND
ARE ACTUALLY AT OUR DIRECTION-
THE BILL SB ONE ONE EIGHT YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR FROM- MISTER MARTIN
FROM MARCH. THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. IS A- CLARIFICATION
TOUCHING. ON THE WAY THAT OUR
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES DO THEIR
LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLAN. AS
WELL AS WHAT KIND OF REMEDIES A
JUDGE MAY BE ABLE TO ORDER- LET
ME ALSO. ALSO ADDRESS THAT THAT
DONE IN PARTICULAR IS THE MAIN
POINT OF THE BILL IS ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT UNIVERSITIES HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REMEDY THE
SITUATION BEFORE- A DRACONIAN
VERDICT WOULD BE. PUT DOWN BUT
LET ME LET ME JUST ALSO JUST
START OFF BY THANKING ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO REALLY WORKED VERY
VERY TIRELESSLY OF THE LAST FEW
WEEKS IT'S AS AS YOU ALL KNOW-
BILLS. WITH THIS DOWN WITH THIS
KIND OF URGENCY DO NOT HAPPEN
VERY OFTEN BUT GIVEN THE- IMPACT
ON FIVE THOUSAND POTENTIAL
FAMILIES WHO WERE NOT GOING TO
GET. A NOTICES OF ADMISSIONS TO
THE UC BERKELEYWE THOUGHT THAT
IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO ACT
AND TO ACT QUICKLY AND SWIFTLY
SO WE'RE VERY PROUD TO BE ABLE
TO PRESENT THESE BILLS TODAY.
WELL LET ME JUST ALSO THANK
SENATOR SKINNER MY COUNTERPART
IN THE SENATE IN ALL OF HER. IN
A TEAM WHO WORKED VERY VERY HARD
ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL AS THE
SENATE PRO TEM- THE SENATE PRO
TEM AS WELL. LET ME ALSO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE.
WHO ARE CHAIRS OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE. COMMITTEES NOW WITH
MR STONE MYSTERY OF US MISS
WICKS AND OBVIOUSLY OUR OUR
GREAT CENTURY HUMANS MCCARTY. AS
WELL AS OUR SPEAKER. SPEAKER
RENDON WHO DID A PHENOMENAL JOB
AND REALLY WORKING TO GET THIS
BILL HERE AT THIS TIME. BUT I
THINK AGAIN IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO REITERATE- WHY
WE'RE HERE. WE'RE HERE BECAUSE-
WE KNOW AS A STATE THERE'S A
VERY LARGE DEMAND FOR OUR PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM. AND WE
NEED ALL THE- DIFFERENT
UNIVERSITIES WHETHER IT'S
BERKELEY OR SAN FRANCISCO STATE
OR SAC STATE HERE. FOR UC DAVIS
IN OUR IN OURLOCAL AREA. TO
CONTINUE TO GROW SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO OFFER ACCESS TO
THIS. EXTRAORDINARY SYSTEM THAT
THE STATE HAS INVESTED A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
OVER THE YEARS SO LET LET ME
START AND WE'LL GO TO SB. ONE
ONE EIGHT. WASHINGTON THE
MISSING MR FUNG HAS ANY COMMENTS
NOPE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO S. B.
R. ONE ONE EIGHT WE HAVE MISTER
MARTIN FROM OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE. HI MARK MY WITH
SIMILAR BUDGET COMMITTEE- SB ONE
EIGHTEEN MAKES THE FOLLOWING
CHANGES THAT CLARIFIES THAT WHEN
I. WHEN CAMPUSES ARE CONDUCTING
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW THEY SHOULD
FOCUS ON CAMPUS POPULATION- IT
STATES THAT CHANGES IN
ENROLLMENT BY ITSELF OR NOT
ENOUGH TO TRIGGER FURTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. AND IT
STATES THAT IF A COURT
DETERMINES THAT THE CAMPUS HAS
INCREASED ITS CAMPUS POPULATION
BEYOND PROJECTIONS IN ITS
PLANNING DOCUMENTS. IT MAY
REQUIRE CAMPUS TO CONDUCT
FURTHER ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
WITHIN EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF THAT
COURT ORDER. IF THE CAMPUS IS
NOT CERTIFIED THAT REVIEW WITHIN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS THEN THE COURT
MAY CAP CAMPUS POPULATION AT THE
NUMBER PREVIOUSLY PLANNED FOR-
IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL APPLIES
THE SECTION RETROACTIVELY- THIS
BILL DOES NOT RELIEVE CAMPUSES
FROM SEA QUOTE IN ANYWAY. WE
THINK THE BILL CLARIFIES THE
SEQUEL PROCESS FOR CAMPUSES. AND
ASSURES THE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
ARE NOT HARMED WHEN THERE IS
LEGAL CONFLICT OVER
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. AS THE
CHAIR NOTED THE BILL SEEKS TO
BALANCE TO STATE PRIORITIES ONE
WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE HIGHER
EDUCATION ACCESS FOR STUDENTS.
AND ONE WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE
THAT CAMPUSES REVIEW- AND
MITIGATE WHEN THEIR POPULATION
IS GROWING. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANKS FOR SMART
WILL GO TO MISTER KHALID BERMAN
FINANCE. AFTER GOOD MORNING ERIC
LEE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WOULD JUST ADD THAT
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THIS BILL
IS INTENDED TO ENSURE
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS
TO HIGHER EDUCATION WHILE
MAINTAINING BROADER C. CLUB-
PROVISIONS TO ASSESS AND
MITIGATE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
OF PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION.
PROJECTS THANK YOU THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM THIS
PERCENT AT ELLIOT. ALLEN AS
JENNIFER PATEL LA OVER HERE JUST
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT THE BILL.
THANK YOU FIVE. TO THE COMMITTEE
. WE GOT WE GOT A VICE SURE- A
FEW QUICK QUESTIONS- TO THE L.
A. O. L. ARE THERE OTHER UC'S R.
C. S. USER COMMITTEE COLLEGES
THAT ARE FACING SIMILAR-
CHALLENGES- AND CAN YOU
IDENTIFY- WHICH- WHICH THOSE ARE
. THERE'S NO CAMPUS THAT WE'RE
AWARE OF IN THE EXACT SAME
POSITION AS A UC BERKELEY. WE
DID ASK YOU NEED TO PROVIDE US
ESTIMATES OF WHERE EACH CAMPUS'S
RELATIVE TO THEIR LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN THERE ARE TWO
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE EXCEEDED
THEIR STUDENT- ESTIMATES UNDER
THEIR MOST RECENT LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS UCLA. AND UC
SANTA BARBARA ARE SLIGHTLY OVER
THEIR TARGETS WHEN IT COMES JUST
TO THE STUDENT ENROLLMENT
LEVELS. THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TAKES OUT THE REFERENCE TO
STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY AND-
FOCUSES ON CAMPUS POPULATION AND
SO NOT ONLY STUDENTS BUT FACULTY
STAFF ALL EMPLOYEES OF THE
CAMPUS NO UC CAMPUS AS AN EXCESS
OF THEIR LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT
PLAN TOTAL CAMPUS POPULATION
ESTIMATES. AND WE'RE NOT WE DID
NOT ASK THAT- I'M SORRY WE ASK
IN FOR AS YES USE SO I'M SORRY I
CAN'T ANSWER THAT SPECIFICALLY
IF THERE ARE SOME CSU CAMPUSES
THAT ARE GETTING CLOSE TO THEIR
MASTER PLAN ESTIMATES. BUT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THESE- VISIONS DO
APPLY TO USE PCS USE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALL HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS PUBLIC AT
A PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS. LAST OCTOBER FOR
YOU REFERENCES AT PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION IS BROADLY DEFINED SO
IT WOULD APPLY TO CAMPUSES AT
ALL THREE PUBLIC STATEMENTS. AND
MY LAST QUESTION IS IN TERMS OF
THE ITS APPLICATIONS THE SEQUEL
OR CHANGES OR NOT NO CHANGES
WHAT WHAT IS YOUR ANALYSIS DOES
THIS BILL. REVISED PHYSICAL
PROVISIONS AYWAY OR IS SEEK.
WORK LEFT. IN PLACE. I WONDER
THE AS IT DOES CHANGE SOME OF
THE PROCEDURAL REQUIREMENTS SO
AND- RATHER THAN LOOKING AT. IN
ENROLLMENT IN ISOLATION IT
ALLOWS CAMPUSES TO LOOK AT THEIR
TOTAL CAMPUS CONTEMPT POPULATION
THAT IS SOMETHING THEY DO NOW-
IT JUST GIVES THEM A LITTLE BIT
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO FOCUS. ON
CAMPUS POPULATION WITHOUT HAVING
TO SPOKE UP ON ANY SUB COMPONENT
OF THEM WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SECRET PROCESS IN ISOLATION AND
ALSO CLARIFIES WHAT HAPPENS IF
THERE IS A FINDING THAT THEY
HAVE EXCEEDED THEIR CAMPUS
POPULATION TOTALS. IT GIVES
CAMPUSES THESE EIGHTEEN MONTH
WINDOWS FOR THE COURT- FOR THEM
TO REMEDY SITUATIONS WITHIN THE
EIGHTEEN MONTHS BEFORE THE
CAMPUS HAS TO TURN AWAY ANY
STUDENTS. SO IT IS TRYING TO
CLARIFY THAT THE SITUATION WENT
MATERIALIZE AGAIN IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE CAMPUSES WHAT HAVE THE
SET EIGHTEEN MONTH PERIOD SO
YOU- UNDERTAKE MEDICATION. OKAY
SO JUST TO BE CLEAR- THIS BILL
REMOVES THAT THE ENROLLMENT
REQUIREMENTS. IN THEIR- IN PLAN
AND IF THEY ARE- EXCEEDING THE-
THE- THE ENROLLMENT CAPS THEN
ORG ENROLLMENT REQUIRED CRITERIA
IT AND THEY HAVE EIGHTEEN MONTHS
TO REMEDY THAT WERE TO DO
ANOTHER IMPACT- AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT. I
THINK THAT'S BASICALLY IT RIGHT
THE EIGHTEENTH MONTH WINDOW I
THINK STARKS WHEN ANTS- IN
CONNECTION TO A COURT CASE SO
THAT THIS SPECIFIC INSTANCE
BEFORE YOU CREDIT REMAINS URIEL
MATERIALIZE OUT PRIOR TO
LITIGATION CAMPUS AS CAN-
BECAUSE WE NEED TO GO THROUGH
THAT LIKE REGULAR C. CORPUS THAT
THE WAY YOU SUMMARIZED IT IS
CONSISTENT WITH OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE WILL
JUST BE THIS DEFINED PERIOD OF
TIME UNDER WHICH CAMPUSES MAY
RESPOND. OKAY BUT ENROLLMENT
LEVELS ARE NO LONGER SO THAT
THAT ROMAN REMOVAL IS THAT IS
THAT MINOR CHANGE THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO UNDER SEQUEL. I'LL
NOT SURE WHETHER YES HAVING A
ONE OF THE ELEMENTS OF THE
BERKELEY COURT CASE WAS THAT
ENROLLMENT COULD BE THE SOLE
FACTOR TRIGGERING A SEQUEL OF
REVIEW AND ENROLLMENT NOW IN
ISOLATION WILL NOT BE SOMETHING
THAT CAN TRIGGER THE DEFINITION
OF A SEQUEL PROJECT NONSTICK
WILL REFUSE WILL HAPPEN FOR ALL
OF THE OTHER REASONS INCLUDING
THINGS THAT WERE CAMPUS
POPULATION IS EXCEEDING. AN
ALLERGY THAT THE COURT MASTER
PLAN TARGETS OKAY I APPRECIATE
THANK YOU. I FORGOT I'M A WE'RE
GONNA ALSO. SB 119% AT THE SAME
TIME SO. NONE OF. THOSE MIGHT
NOT ALSO MISSED WE WANT TO GO
AHEAD WITH SB ONE NINETEEN AND
THEN WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS ON
OTHER ITEMS. YES MISTER CHAIR-
I'M ACTUALLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HERE TO PRESENT AN
ESTIMATED NINETEEN WHICH IS A
PLAN TO BUILD JUNIOR. THAT
AMENDS THE CURRENT BUDGET ACT-
THIS BILL RE APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
COUNTIES EFFORTS TO UPGRADE OR
REPLACE MONNING SYSTEM. ALLOWING
COUNTIES TO CONTINUE SPENDING
FUNDS THROUGH THE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR ELECTION CYCLE- THE BILL
ADDS BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WILL PROVIDE THE COMMISSION.
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
OR POST WITH FLEXIBILITY TO
SHIFT EXISTING BONDS BETWEEN ITS
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT. THE CURRENT
YOUR IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TWO
RELATING TO PEACE OFFICER
CERTIFICATION- IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THIS BUDGET BUILDING WHICH ALSO
REQUIRES NOTIFICATION TO THE
GLVC BEFORE ANY FUNDS CAN BE
TRANSFERRED. I'M THE ILL
CORRECTS THE NAME OF A COW. CAN
AND FINALLY INCLUDES OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO CONTROL
SECTIONS NINETEEN POINT FIVE SIX
AND NINETEEN POINT SEVEN OF THE
CURRENT BUDGET ACT- AND THAT IS
IT I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS. WHERE DID YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS AS WELL. JUST
COMPUTERS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND NO COMMENTS
BY HRE IF YOU HAVE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS FOR US THANK
YOU WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO MR
FONG. MY ONE QUESTION TO THE
PREMIER FINANCE IN TERMS OF THE-
SB ONE NINETEEN. IS- WHAT IS THE
URGENCY TO IMPLEMENT THE
TRANSFER OF FUNDS- WHEN IT COMES
SUPPOSED IS THERE A RATIONAL
WHAT'S THE RATIONALE BEHIND THAT
. CHARMANDER BONTA THERE A
THERE'S CURRENTLY IN STAFF TO
THE DATE OF JANUARY ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WHICH- UNDER
SB TWO- REQUIRES AGENCIES THAT
ARE PLAYING PEACE OFFICERS TO
TRANSMIT CERTAIN INFORMATION TO
POST. AND SO POST IS- GETTING
READY TO IMPLEMENT TO BEGIN
IMPLEMENTATION OF NINETY SYSTEM
TO ALLOW FOR THAT DATA TRANSFER.
SO THAT DATE JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IN STATUTE IS
WHAT'S DRIVING- THE CURRENT
NEED. OKAY THE TO THE TO THE
ELIO- IN TERMS OF. IT MADE IT IS
NORMAL I GUESS OR MAYBE I'M
TRYING UNDERSTAND- THE URGENCY
HERE. I'M NOT SURE SO WHEN WE-
AND REVIEWED HOPE CLOSE AS A-
REQUEST FOR THE BUDGET YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. I'M
INCLUDING RESOURCES FOR- THE IT
SYSTEM AS WELL AS OTHER ASPECTS
OF IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TWO. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAD
NOTED IN OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
AND IS THAT THE TIME LINES- ARE
PRETTY TIGHT FOR THEM IN
PARTICULAR TO PROCURE THE JESUS
DANCE. AND SINCE THE DEPARTMENT
HAS DONE A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF WORK IN THE CURRENT YEAR. TO
PREPARE FOR INSTANCE IN THE BILL
BASICALLY CHECK AFFECTING
EVERYONE IN THIS YEAR BUT THERE
IS A ONE YEAR DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THEM BEFORE
THEY HAVE TO HAVE IT SYSTEM UP
AND RUNNING. TO RECEIVE REPORTS
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES-
AND SO THEY'VE DONE A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF WORK TO-
THAT BEACON THE PREPARATION FOR
PROCURING THE EIGHTY SYSTEM AS
WELL AS PUTTING PROCEDURES IN
PLACE. AND SO AND IT APPEARED
STAFF HOST MAYBE READY TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH PROCURING STARTING
THE PROCUREMENT AND IT SYSTEMS
IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO.
AND THERE WOULD BE A JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
NOTIFICATION WHEN RESTAURANTS
ARE TRANSFERRED I'M AND THAT
WOULD JUST ALLOW THEM TO MOVE
MORE QUICKLY I'M AS AS YOU'RE
PROBABLY AWARE GETTING AND I. T.
SYSTEM PROCURED AND IMPLEMENTED.
WITHIN A SIX MONTH TIME FRAME
THIS IS A PRETTY SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME. I'M SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS SURE WELL
THE SAKE OF WINDOWS HAVE ISSUES
WITH IT SYSTEMS AYE AYE I THINK
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME THAT-
TIMES OUT. IN WE'RE MOVING. UP
FOR THE ONE SO IS THERE. TWO
YEARS THAT THAT THAT POST IS
READY BY OTHER DEPARTMENTS ARE
NOT. YES RIGHT OUR UNDERSTANDING
IS THIS WOULD ALLOW AND I CAN
DEFERRED A PERMANENT FINANCING
THIS THIS WOULD JUST ALLOW THEM
TO ACCESS THE FUNDING MORE
QUICKLY. IF THEY ARE ABLE TO AND
I THINK DEPARTMENT FINANCE MIGHT
BE IN A BETTER POSITION BY THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD
EARLIER IN THE YEAR WITH HOST
ABIT SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE TRYING
TO EDGE HI CARE SOMETHING THAT'S
RELATIVELY OFF THE SHELF- AND
BY. GIVING A SPEECH YOU WENT
INTO AFFECTED THIS JANUARY WIND
BUT THE SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE
REPLACED BY NEXT JANUARY ONE AND
ADDS TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY ARE
READY TO GO ON THE PROCUREMENT
AND THAT SYSTEM ACCESSING THESE
DOLLARS SOONER. WHEN A SYSTEM IN
BEING ABLE TO HAVE IT UP AND
RUNNING BY NEXT JANUARY FIRST IN
ORDER TO IMPLEMENT THE
LEGISLATION. OKAY SO BACK TO THE
FORMER FINANCE SO IS THAT SO
THAT'S AN ACCURATE DESCRIPTION
EAT THIS THIS INFORMATION SYSTEM
THIS IS THE SYSTEM'S GOING TO BE
READY TO GO. BY JANUARY FIRST.
OF TWENTY TWENTY. THREE YES AND
AS MR MAN. THIS DOES GIVE THAT.
AND I DID THREE. SO RATHER THAN
IMPLEMENT STARTING JULY ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO START THREE MONTHS EARLY
SO AND- AND- THREE MONTHS- IN
REGARDS TO PROCUREMENT WILL BE
HELPFUL OR THE DEPARTMENT TO
MEET THAT DATE OF JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH. THANK GONNA GO MISTER
. YEAH YOU THANK YOU- MR TANG I
JUST WANTED TO COMMENT FURTHER
ON THIS ACTION ITEM RELATED TO.
SB ONE EIGHTEEN AND UC BERKELEY
SO FIRST AND FOREMOST I THIN
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE WILL
GET UNANIMOUS- EMBRACE ON THE
FLOOR LATER ON TODAY IN THIS
ISSUE THAT WE WANTED TO TACKLE
RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO LEAVE. THOUSANDS OF QUALIFIED
CALIFORNIANS ATTEMPTING TO
ENROLL THE UC BERKELEY THIS FALL
IN A LURCH AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WAS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
BRING ABOUT A FIX AND- YOU KNOW
SEQUEL EVERY FORMALLY TO HOUSING
IS AN ELUSIVE ISSUE THAT ARE NOT
TO RESOURCES CHAIR WOULD ALLUDE
TO AND PEOPLE CAN STILL. LOOK AT
THAT THAT'S KIND OF A LONGER
TERM ISSUE THIS IS AN IMMEDIATE
ISSUE HOW WE CAN FIX THE ISSUE
AT UC BERKELEY- FULLY ENROLL
STUDENTS THIS FALL AS WAS AS WAS
PLANNED. AND THEN- TO YOUR
QUESTION MISTER VICE CHAIR- FONG
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THIS IN
PLACE SO WE DON'T HAVE ISSUES
AND OTHER HIRING CAMPUS IS
MAINLY UC CAMPUSES BUT ONE OR
TWO- CS USE MAY HAVE THIS ISSUE
IN CITIES WHERE THERE YOU KNOW
THAT CONSTRAINT. WITH BUILDING
NEW HOUSING AND HOW DO YOU KNOW
ISSUES WITH LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
CONCERNED ABOUT SUCH GROWTH- BUT
THE BIG PICTURE HERE I THINK AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE- S. THING
WHERE THE- YEAR AS WELL. AS NEED
BUILD MORE HOW. AND CAMPUSES YOU
KNOW THAT'S THE FIGHT HERE- LAST
YEAR WE PUT ASIDE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS TO BUILD MORE COLLEGE
HOUSING AT UCC ISSUED COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WERE DOING THAT RIGHT
NOW- WE HAVE A PUSH THIS YEAR
FOR ANOTHER FIVE BILLION- THE
IRONY HERE AT BERKELEY. WILL SAY
IS THAT THERE IS A PROPOSAL TO
BUILD MORE STUDENT HOUSING WHO
WAS. ARGUED AGAINST BY THE SAME
APPLICATION FILED THIS AGAINST
THE ENROLLMENT INCREASE SO. YOU
KNOW THEY DON'T WANT THE HOUSING
BILLS AND THEN THEY SUED FOR
MORE MOMENT BECAUSE NONE OF
HOUSING SO- WHAT YOU KNOW WE
REALLY KNOW THEIR TRUE TRUE
PRIORITIES HERE AND THAT'S JUST
YOU KNOW NIMBYS WHO DON'T WANT
MORE- HIGHER EDUCATION
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE KNOW SO
KEY TO OUR- ECONOMIC FUTURE
UPWARD MOBILITY FOR STUDENTS AND
SO. OU KNOW WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE KEEP. OUR EYES ON THE ON
THE PRICE AND FOCUSING ON
INCREASING ENROLLMENT AS WELL AS
PROVIDING STUDENT HOUSING TO
HELP CURRENT STUDENTS AS WELL
AS- A FUTURE- POPULATION IN
THESE CAMPUSES SO- THANK YOU TO.
OUR LEADERSHIP TEAM ARE BUDGET
CHAIR SPEAKER AND EVERYBODY IN
OUR STAFF FOR COMING UP WITH
THAT- THE SOLUTION WE CAN VOTE
ON EMBRACE TODAY. AND. I THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. AT THE
COMMISSION. WITH THREE. THANK
YOU CHAIR- I WOULD THINK- BUT
CHAIR AND OTHERS THAT WERE
INVOLVED IN COMING UP- WITH THIS
LEGISLATION YOU KNOW CLEARLY-
AUTHORS ARE ATTEMPTING TO PUT
THE INTEREST OF STUDENTS FIRST-
AND I THINK THAT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO AND I DON'T QUESTION
OF THEIR GOOD INTENTIONS- YOU
KNOW IF THE CONSEQUENCE. OF THE
COURTS IN JUNCTION IS TO DENY
INCOMING STUDENTS PARTICULARLY
IN STATE STUDENTS. YOU KNOW THE
SPOT THAT THEY EARNED AT UC
BERKELEY WE SHOULD AVOID THAT WE
ALL HAVE CONSTITUENTS THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED AND BECAUSE
OF OUR ACTION TODAY- THE
STUDENTS THAT. SHOULD BE
ADMITTED TO UC BERKELEY WILL BE
ABLE TO BE ADMITTED BY THE
UNIVERSITY HOWEVER. THAT
CONSEQUENCE IN THIS CASE IS NOT
BECAUSE OF THE ANALYSIS
REQUIREMENTS OF SEEK WHAT THAT
SEE WHAT REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT IN
CLEAR AND REASONABLE IN FACT
THESE REQUIREMENTS HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE. AND THEIR PURPOSE IS TO
CLARIFY AND LIMIT UNIVERSITY
SEQUEL OBLIGATIONS WHEN THEY
ADOPT THEIR LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS- IN FACT THE
CONSEQUENCE IN THIS CASE IS THE
DIRECT RESULT OF THE UNIVERSITY
DISREGARDING THE CLEAR
REQUIREMENTS TO ANALYZE CHANGES
IN ENROLLMENT. WITZIG WHICH
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED AT UC
BERKELEY DUE PRIMARILY TO THE
UC'S DECISION TO EMPHASIZE
ADMITTING OUT OF STATE STUDENTS
. THIS ISN'T REALLY A SEQUEL
LITIGATION RUN AMOK BUT A CASE
WHERE UC BERKELEY DISREGARDED
THE CLEAR LONGSTANDING
REQUIREMENT TO PLAN FOR INCREASE
ENROLLMENT. SO WHAT'S OUR
SOLUTION YOU KNOW THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY REWARDS THE
MISTAKES OF THE UC I BUT I HOPE
THAT OTHER UNIVERSITIES WILL NOT
COMMIT THESE MISTAKES AND PUT
STUDENTS ADMISSIONS AT RISK. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
LETTING THEM OFF THE HOOK FOR
THIS. IS A BILL. YOU KNOW DOES
NOT ACTUALLY SUBSTITUTE AN
ANALYSIS OF CAMPUS POPULATION
FOR ENROLLMENT WHAT IT DOES IS
ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT TO
ANALYZE ENROLLMENT CHANGES
CREATING AN INCENTIVE TO UNDER
STATE STUDENT NUMBERS TO REDUCE
PLANNING AND MITIGATION
REQUIREMENTS. I DON'T QUESTION
THE GOOD INTENTIONS OF THE
AUTHORS AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THEY INVOLVED OTHER CHAIRS OF
COMMITTEES WHOSE JURISDICTION IS
UNDER SEEK WHAT. BUT THIS RUSH
JOB UNFORTUNATELY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAD TO DO AND SKIPPED
THE POLICY PROCESS AND REAL
PUBLIC REVIEW AS A RESULT. I
KNOW THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE TO DO FOR STUDENTS AND
I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS- BUT IN THE FUTURE I
BELIEVE THAT THIS. NEEDS MORE
REVIEW POLICY REVIEW GOING
THROUGH THE POLICY PROCESS AND
THE APPROPRIATE COMMITTEES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE WITH MYSTERY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. ON THIS ISSUE AND
BRING THIS- MEASURED WITH SO
QUICKLY. I IN FACT YOU KNOW I
EVEN HAD CONSTITUENTS WITHIN MY
OWN DISTRICT THAT WHEN FAMILIES
ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE-
UNPRECEDENTED CORPORAL UC
BERKELEY. AND I THINK TODAY'S
FIX WHILE OF COURSE THE
BEGINNING OF A LONG TERM
SOLUTION IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE- I
NOT ONLY DOES IT IN FACT AFFECT.
A PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS COMING UC
BERKELEY BUT WE SAW THE TEEING
UP OF LITIGATION AND OTHER USES
LIKE SANTA BARBARA OR OTHER
COASTAL. OR ANY A LOT OF OTHER
SCHOOLS AND I AND MY
CONSTITUENTS HAD WORRIED THAT
THIS WILL REVERBERATE ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. WHICH COULD BE GET NINE
LOTS AND LOTS OF STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOCIOECONOMIC
MOBILITY AND EDUCATION AT OUR
FINEST EDUCATION SOLUTIONS. I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT THIS IS
INCLUSIVE OF ALL OUR EDUCATION
SOLUTIONS AND NOT JUST UC
BERKELEY. BECAUSE REALLY IF WE
ALLOW. THE WHIMS OF A MINORITY
OF FOLKS IN THOSE TOWNS TO HOLD
HOSTAGE THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIANS. WE DO HAVE A
REALLY SERIOUS PROBLEMS AND I
AGREE THAT THIS IS A GOOD. FIX
IT BEGINNING OF A CONVERSATION
WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO BE HAVING.
BUT I'M REALLY GLAD THAT- WE'RE
ABLE TAKE DECISIVE ACTION AND I
REALLY WOULD EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
HAS IMMEDIATE. ONE OF THE I
THINK RARE TIMES IN THIS
LEGISLATURE WE HAVE AN IMMEDIATE
EFFECT AND BENEFIT TO FAMILIES
WITH A CONSTITUENCY. ACT AS
AGENTS ARE GOING TO BE VERY
THANKFUL THAT WE'RE ABLE TO TAKE
SUCH QUICK ACCESS SO I THANK YOU
AGAIN- SEARCHING FOR YOUR QUICK
ACTION ON THIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MYSTERON US. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS IS A MORE OF A
COMMENT OVER THE WHOLE- UC
SYSTEM I KNOW WE'RE HERE TALKING
ABOUT CONTINUING HERE WITH UC
BERKELEY AND SOME OF THE ONLINE-
THINGS IN COURSES THAT WE'RE
TALKING A BUT THERE WAS AN AUDIT
THAT WAS DONE. ON THE UC SYSTEM
THAT IDENTIFIED OVER. FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND NATIVE AMERICAN
REMAINS IN THOSE REMAINS ARE
STILL IN THE PROCESS TO BE
REPATRIATED BACK. SO I WANTED
TO. MAKE SURE IN ENCOURAGE- AND
MAKE SURE THE LEGISLATURE STILL
KNOWS THAT THOSE REMAINS HAVE
NOT BEEN TOTALLY- REPATRIATED
BACK TO NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO AS WE'RE MOVING FORWARD ON
THESE TYPES OF A- REQUEST IN
THESE TYPES OF ACTIONS THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. THOSE
ACTIONS OF REPATRIATING. NATIVE
AMERICAN REMAINS BACK TO THE
RIGHT FOR PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT THOSE ARE
ONGOING PROCESSES AND WILL BE
MONITORING THAT TO ENSURE THAT
THAT CONTINUES TO MOVE. IN A
FORWARD DIRECTION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY SEEING NONE WE
WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT IF
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WAS TO WISH
TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMITTEE COULD
PLEASE LET UP BY THE MICROPHONE. YOU'RE FREE TO GO AHEAD YOU
HAVE ONE MINUTE. HELLO MY NAME
IS JOSH TOMLIN I'M A CURRENT UC
DAVIS STUDENT IN A BERKELEY CITY
COLLEGE TRANSFER STUDENT I'M
HERE TODAY TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
AB ONE SIX EIGHT AND SB ONE
EIGHTEEN. STUDENTS ARE NOT
POLLUTANTS AND FREEZES LIKE THIS
CAUSE INEQUITABLE ACCESS TO OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS EVAN CENTER AND I'M A UC
DAVIS STUDENT. I THINK IT IS
BEYOND THE OBVIOUS THAT IT IS.
UNJUST AND CRUEL TO TRY TO LIMIT
STUDENTS WHO HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ACCEPTED INTO THE UNIVERSITY
FROM BEING ABLE TO ATTEND FOR
TAKING LEGAL ACTION. AND SO I'M
HAPPY TO SEE THAT WE'RE MAKING
SWIFT PROGRESS ON TRYING TO.
MAKE LEGISLATION TO FIGHT THAT.
IF THIS ISN'T SUCCESSFUL AND
STUDENTS WERE DENIED FROM
UNIVERSITY THEY ALREADY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO. WE WILL
CREATE A MORE UNJUST HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM. AND FURTHER
STONE THE FUTURE OF THE STATE
ECONOMICALLY. AND EDUCATIONAL.
PLEASE I URGE YOU PASS AB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT AND SB ONE EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS EIGHT
IN MORRIS I'M A UC DAVIS STUDENT
AND A TRANSFER STUDENT FROM
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I AM HERE TO
SUPPORT. AT AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
AND SB EIGHTEEN BECAUSE WE
SHOULD NOT BE DENYING STUDENTS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GAIN ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL MOBILITY BY ATTENDING
OUR AMAZING UNIVERSITIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH LEGAL PROCESS
AND INSTEAD SHOULD BE GIVEN THAT
EIGHTEEN MONTH PERIOD TO. HAVE
FOR UNIVERSITIES TO REVIEW- IF
THEIR GUIDELINES AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT STUDENTS ARE NOT BEING
DENIED ADMISSION- BECAUSE OF
THESE LAWSUITS THANK YOU. HELLO
MY NAME IS A RUSSIAN I'M IN I'M
A FOURTH YEAR UNDERGRAD STUDENT
AT UC DAVIS I'M HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE EIGHTEEN- AND
SUPPORT THE WORK OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS DOING- TO ENFORCE
THE FACT THAT STUDENTS ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY. NOT POLLUTANTS
THANK YOU. MICHAEL THE DART ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ESPECIALLY MISTER CHAIR.
AND JUST SUPPORT ON- SENATE BILL
ONE EIGHTEEN THANKS. THANK YOU
SEEN NO OTHER SPEAKERS HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE- PHONE LINES OPERATOR
EITHER. MISTER CHAIR YEAH PLEASE
PLEASE START WITH THE ON THE
PHONE COMMENTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT OVER THE PHONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD YOU MAY PRESS THE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE SEVERAL IN Q. WERE YOU
READY TO BEGIN. PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU FOR THE FIRST TIME
LINE TWENTY NINE TO NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN CLOSE
BERGEN BEHALF OF SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY I DO WANT TO EXPRESS THE
COUNTIES CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PROCESS INVOLVED HERE WITHOUT
ANY OPPORTUNITY FOR THE COUNTY
TO REVIEW ITS IMPACT UPON THE
COUNTY. AND TO HAVE ANY INPUT IN
THE PROCESS WE DO BELIEVE WE
WILL HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS
BILL AND ITS LANGUAGES UNDER
REVIEW RIGHT NOW WE HOPE WE CAN
WORK WITH YOU- ON SUBSEQUENT
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS OF THIS PASSES. OUT
SHORTLY THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE THIRTEEN ONE THREE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT
PUNGENCY ON BEHALF OF THE U. A.
W. TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE THE
NEW A. W. SIXTY EIGHT TEN
REPRESENTING OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND UNDERGRADS GRADUATE
STUDENTS POSTDOCS AND ACADEMIC
RESEARCHERS AT UC U. STRONGLY
SUPPORT- SB ONE EIGHTEEN- AND
THE SOLUTION. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE
THAT YOU SEE STUDENTS AND
WORKERS HAVE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT COMMENTED LINE. FIFTEEN
ONE FIVE. HELLO GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS GLENN CODER I AM A
GRADUATE STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AND
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA GRADUATE AND
PROFESSIONAL COUNCIL CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT- THIS LEGISLATION IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY- IT
PROVIDES CLARITY TO EXISTING LAW
AND ENSURE THAT CURRENT AND
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS ARE TERMS
BECAUSE OF AN ONGOING POLICY
DISAGREEMENTS. I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
IMPROVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING I'M
IN THE AREA SURROUNDING ARE YOU.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COMMON LINE
NINE.
HI MY BLACK AND THEN- UC
BERKELEY LAW STUDENTS ARE BEING
ASKED TO GIVE YOU CAN DESIGNATE
AND THE FIRST IN MY FAMILY TO
ATTEND COLLEGE I'M HERE TODAY TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS ON SB
ONE EIGHTEEN AND AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE AND
THE STATE HAS RECOGNIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF INCREASING
ACTIVITY THE FIRST STUDENTS LIKE
MYSELF HOWEVER THERE IS A RECENT
COURT RULING IS COMPLETELY
COUNTER TO OUR STATE CRITICAL
PRIORITY AT A TIME WHEN YOU SEE
WITH THEHIGHEST NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS IN BOTH THE MOST
DIVERSE CLASS. WITH THE MOST
ACTIVE THAT SUCH ACT WHICH
MEANING WHILE BALANCING THE NEED
TO MITIGATE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
IN THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON SB ONE
EIGHTEEN AB. ONE SIXTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. NEXT COM FROM LINE.
TWENTY YES GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN EVERYONE MY NAME IS
TAMMY AGAIN ANYA OKAY VICE
CHANCELLOR OF THE MOMENT AND
DEAN OF UNDERGRADUATE ADMISSIONS
CAN'T YOU SEE BERKELEY ALLY
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND I'LL KEEP MY REMARKS.
BRIEF I KNOW THAT THIS HAS BEEN
DEBATED IN THE COURTS AND THE
MEDIA THERE'S BEEN A DEEP
ANALYSIS AND A SEQUEL AND LONG
RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLAN WELL I'M
NOT A LAWYER OR POLITICIAN I
JOIN YOU ALL TODAY AS A CITIZEN
AS AN EDUCATOR AND ALSO THE
GRADUATE STUDENT IN THE GRADUATE
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION AT BERKELEY
WHO JUST WANTS TO SPEAK TO THE
IMPACT. OF THIS INJUNCTION I
BERKELEY ACROSS THE STATE IN THE
NATION THE IMPACT OF OUR DEGREE
A SIGNIFICANT NOT JUST FOR
STUDENTS BUT FOR THEIR FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES RECENTLY WE ARE
GOING TO THE TOP INSTITUTION NOT
BECAUSE OF OUR SELECTIVITY BUT
BECAUSE OF OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SOCIAL MOBILITY FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. A COLLEGE
EDUCATION CAN DISRUPT
GENERATIONAL POVERTY AND IN FACT
PUT PEOPLE IN POSITIONS TO
GENERATE GENERATIONAL WEALTH
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
WE'VE BEEN SPEAKING ABOUT HOW
THIS INJUNCTION WOULD RESULT IN
THE AMOUNT OF OPPORTUNITIES THE
NIGHT OF DESERVING STUDENTS WHO
HAVE ALREADY GONE THROUGH TWO
YEARS OF A PANDEMIC EDUCATION
THEY'D BILL GIVE US A CHANCE TO
RESTORE THE OPPORTUNITY TO THE
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PEOPLE BETTER
CONVERSATION I'VE BEEN HEARING
TODAY THANK YOU AT THE THING IN
THE SKINNER FOR THE AFRICAN SB
ONE EIGHTEEN AND A. B. ONE SIXTY
EIGHT AND I YOU ALL ABOUT YES TO
ALLOW THE DELAY. THE PROMISE OF
A BREAK EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND
THE FAMILIES OF ALL THE
SACRIFICE ALTHOUGH TWO YEARS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I NEXT
COMMUNIST. SEVEN THANK YOU MY
NAME IS GERRY DEMARCO AND ON A
SCALE MEMBER USED CRUZ I'M HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF PROPOSED-
EIGHTY ONE EIGHT AND ONE EIGHT
TO PROVIDE CLEAR AROUND CAN
PLANNING IN A MOMENT IT. JOB OF
THE BILLS WILL HELP STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES DIRECTLY THE MIDDLE OF
THE PHENOMENA THAT STAFF AND
WILL ALSO. THE CAST OF THE POWER
TWO YEARS AND TRAINED AS A IN
THE BUILDING TEN TO FROM CLEAR
IN CERTAIN OUR CREW TO A STAY
COOL IN YOUR CAN. THOUGH NOT A
MEMBER OF THE CAN IS HARD NOT TO
IMAGINE HOW ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS CASE COULD BE LEVERAGED
AGAINST THE UNIVERSITY THE OTHER
LOCATIONS ACROSS THE STATE AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING INCREASED
CLARITY. NOT TO BE IN THE SAME
SITUATION IN THE FUTURE THANK
YOU TIME YOUR SUPPORT OKAY. OUR
NEXT HOME. IS FROM LINE TO. HI
JOHN I'M CALLING FROM AREA
COUNCIL AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE AT ONE SIXTY EIGHT SB ONE
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. A LINE OF.
FOURTEEN ONE FOUR. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN TANG AND COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DICK ACKERMAN I'M A
FORMER MEMBER OF THE STATE
ASSEMBLY STATE SENATE I'M A
BERKELEY GRADUATE AND CO CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION I WANT.
YOUR PROPOSAL TO ENSURE STUDENTS
ACCESS TO QUALITY HIGHER
EDUCATION OFFERED BY UC AND CSU
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE PROTECT
THIS ASSET ACCESS FOR ALL FUTURE
STUDENTS AND GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED AND
BECOME PROTECT PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF OUR STATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OUR NEXT COMMENTED
LINE. SEVENTEEN HI I'M ABOUT TO
GO TACKLE FROM WALNUT CREEK I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL THE
DISHONESTY OF PRIVILEGE PEOPLE
DON'T WANT OTHER TO AFFORD A
HOME IN EDUCATION FOR THE MOST
SELFISH REASONS IS EVERYTHING
THAT IS WRONG WITH AMERICA
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE A LEADER
AND CHANGE IT. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE. TWENTY SIX. HELLO
MY NAME IS JORDAN BEEN ON A KIND
OF A HARD CALL ME AND THEY HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND SUPPORT
SB ONE EIGHTEEN AND AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT WE TRULY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE PROPER GETTING THESE
TWO BILLS TODAY AND TAKING A
CONCRETE STEP IN ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE RISEN FROM THE RECENT
COURT DECISION THAT PLATE THE
CAP ON A REAL MAD AT UC
BERKELEY. STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE
EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION AND SHOULD NOT
BE PREVENTED FROM ATTENDING A
PREMIER HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTION DUE TO A CORD ROW
MAKE CAP CALLED BY CUBA THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OUR NEXT COMMENTED
LINE. EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT. MY
NAME IS HARVEY SMITH- BUT FORMER
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY FORMER
EMPLOYEE MY SON ALSO HAS BEEN A
STUDENT AT BERKELEY- I OPPOSE
THE BILL DOES UC BERKELEY HAS
KNOWN ABOUT THIS- LACK OF
HOUSING FOR OVER HALF A CENTURY
AND NOW IT'S BECOME A CRISIS-
WHICH PUTS TREMENDOUS PRESSURE
ON LOW INCOME STUDENTS- IT
GENTRIFIED THE CITY- LOW INCOME
TO PUT THAT IN BERKELEY L. CAN
HARDLY AFFORD TO LIVE HERE. THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN POPULATION OF
BERKELEY HAS DIED DECLINE
PRECIPITOUSLY SO YOU NEED TO PUT
ALL THIS INTO CONTEXT AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A CRISIS
CREATED BY BERKELEY- SO PLEASE
DO NOT PASS THESE BILLS PLEASE
LOOK AT IT MORE DEEPLY. OUR NEXT
COMMENTED LINE THIRTY ONE. HELLO
MY NAME IS EVAN JERKY PRESIDENT
AND SCOTT SALLY CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX
EIGHT SB ONE ON A- THANK. THE
LINE THIRTY THREE. I'M SELBACH
AVOID- TWO DEGREES FROM BERKELEY
AND I LIVED IN BURKE I LIVE IN
BERKELEY- WE OPPOSE INCREASING
USE C. BERKELEY'S ENROLLMENT
UNDER S. B. ONE ONE EIGHT FOR
THE SIMPLE REASON THAT THE
UNIVERSITY DOES NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO HANDLE MORE
STUDENTS. ACCORDING TO UC
BERKELEY'S DATA MORE THAN 10% OF
CURRENT BERKELEY STUDENTS SUFFER
HOMELESSNESS DURING THEIR
EDUCATION IN ADDITION MORE THAN
15% SUFFER FROM FOOD INSECURITY
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS WILL PUT
MORE PRESSURE ON THE LOCAL
HOUSING MARKET INCREASE RENTS
FOR EVERYBODY HITTING LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND LOW INCOME NON
STUDENTS FAMILIES THE HARDEST.
WE DON'T WANT STUDENTS TO HAVE
TO LIVE IN CARS CAMPERS IN HOTEL
ROOMS LIKE THEY'VE BEEN DOING IN
SANTA BARBARA AND MORE STUDENTS
WILL RESULT IN MORE CREDIT
CLASSES AND STRETCH STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES MAKING IT HARD
TO GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS WE'D
LIKE TO SEE THE LEGISLATURE
INSTEAD. INCREASE ENROLLMENT
ONLY AFTER UC HAS INCREASED
HOUSING FOR THEIR STUDENTS THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT COMMENT IS LINE
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING ADAM
RACKLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
RIGHT HERE IN OUR SUPPORT BURKE
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT AND SB
ONE EIGHTEEN ONE EMPHASIZED THAT
THE NEED TO ACCEPT THESE
PROJECTS UNPACKED THESE BILLS IS
PRECISELY BECAUSE HE WAS ABUSED
BY THE VERY GROUPS THAT SAY
THERE IS OVERCROWDING ARE ALSO
THE SAME GROUPS THAT USE THE
STATUTE TO BLOCK HOUSING AT THE
UNIVERSITY'S DEPARTMENT CLEAR.
I'VE ALWAYS SUPPORT THIS BROADER
REFORM IS NEEDED FOR THE GENERAL
REQUEST THAT YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE HAVE LINE THIRTY
NINE. HI MY NAME IS CODER NEIL
I'M CALLING FOR ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND YOU SEE A LONG LIST
AND A LONG TIME AREA RESIDENT
FOR YEARS EMERGING MY SUPPORT
FOR BOTH BILLS WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL THAT AS WE DROP THE
HOUSING SHORTAGE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES WE ARE
DOING IT BY KILLING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ARE JUST TRYING TO GET THEIR
PUTTING BROCK. THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR THERE NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
OPERATOR ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. NOT SEEING ANY
ANY MORE COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. REPUBLICAN
ROOMS LEFT SO ALL WITH THAT WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WILL BE TAKING THE
TWO BILLS UP ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR TODAY AT ONE O'CLOCK. IN
COMMITTEES AT CHURCH THANK YOU.